[Music]
for almost a decade al boy has lurked
behind the curtain of mainstream
releases with a small but devout
following inspired by little more than
its retro aesthetic but the screenshots
and teaser videos early on didn't show
was the humor the heartfelt
personalities and the disasters that
befall their otherwise bright and
uplifting world alibi had the makings of
a modern classic all along but it's not
until you break through the surface that
you're blinded by its artistic
brilliance
it begins with Otis our mute protagonist
and the village runt during a stressful
dream where his professor in dark
figments criticized his inadequacies
it's a powerful setup that endears our
hero but in short order concerns of a
nearby pirate sighting explodes into a
full-on emergency as Otis's village and
a nearby metropolis come under a
full-blown assault with no one to hold
him back Otis teams up with a military
mechanic getti to fight back those quick
to label owl boy as another in a long
line of pixelated games aren't
technically wrong but were many retro
titles aimed ape 8 or 16 bit grafix
Hellboy does its own thing it doesn't
have a limited color palette and its
pixel resolution changes based on the
scene in hand from subterranean
creatures to ancient structures ala
boy's art tackles multiple themes and
subjects with consistently impressive
execution
a Lavoie is still old-school but not
just in this presentation also in its
storytelling there's no voice acting and
events are set in stone with nary a
major decision-making opportunity in
sight the plot manages to avoid
predictability not only through a
handful of twists but by allowing
characters to evolve throughout the
course of the game sad moments aren't
swept under the rug by unreasonably
optimistic outlooks and positivity they
stay with your squad and fundamentally
alter their outlook on the mission and
their own identity in surprising ways
when you first take control of Otis in
the real world darting around floating
islands and chatting with other
anthropomorphize creatures makes for a
pleasant experience and while the open
air in bright colors deserve some credit
it's the orchestrated soundtrack that
solidifies elbows shifting atmosphere in
tone
violas and flutes and still merriment at
first but this innocence is short-lived
when invading pirates set to dismantle
this society by taking control of
powerful relics oboes drone and cellos
growl to the slow beat of a heavy drum
when the dust settles in the second half
of your journey kicks off sprightly
piano compositions provide a much-needed
respite from the stress of a society
under attack
[Music]
your Trek to the pirate's den takes you
through expansive spaces and into the
heart of sprawling cave systems where
Buccaneers and Wildlife alike lie in
wait Otis can only dash into enemies
stunning them at best however with the
help of a handy teleportation device he
can summon one of his three partners
into his claws mid-flight to utilize
their long-range blaster shotgun or
webbing that can ensnare enemies and be
used as a grappling hook to escape
dangerous situations
Otis is unfortunately a tad slow by
default which causes you to span his -
move repeatedly to keep things moving
outside of combat there is a modest
equipment upgrade system driven by
collecting and turning in coins you find
in chests but a keen eye and fast
reflexes are more critical to success
than any upgrades purchased during your
adventure
knowing that victory came from a show of
skill rather than your ability to
collect upgrades is gratifying but you
do walk away from the game with the
sinking feeling that his upgrade system
has unrealized potential with death
pacing elbow steadily mixes combat and
exploration with measured stealth
challenges fast paced escape sequences
and entertaining exchanges between
characters the chase and escape
sequences in particular are some of the
most impressive moments in the game
throwing you into a harrowing race
against time in the face of tightly
choreographed hazards these scenes are
challenging and filled with visual
effects that add to the sense of danger
and they can be overwhelming at first
but should you die not to worry how abou
never truly punishes you for failure
allowing you to restart immediately from
the last room you enter
[Music]
El Bulli is consistently charming and
surprising and while its final act
raises the bar on every front it's
bittersweet when it comes to a close as
you relish the outcome of the final
battle you can't help but reflect on the
beginning of your adventure and how far
the world and its players have come
you'll never be able to play alibi for
the first time again but the memories of
this Magic Moments stick with you this
is more than a treat for fans of
old-school games alibi is a heartfelt
experience that will touch anyone with
an affinity for great art and
storytelling
[Music]
[Music]